في المقابل ارشيفه الوطنيه الامريكيه ما
قاله الرئيس الساده دونالد ترامب وموحاموه
لان القانون يسمح للترانب بالاحتفاظ
بالسجلات الرئاسيه لمده عامين لمراجعتها
ومعرفه ما هو شخصي منها وما هو رئاسي وذكر
الارشيف الوطني
يطلب تسليم جميع السجلات الرؤساء ونوابهم
الى اداره المحفوظات والسجلات الوطنيه في
نهايه ادارتهم واضاف الارشيف الوطني في
بيانه انه لا يوجد نص في القانون يسمح
للرؤساء بالاحتفاظ بالسجلات بعد مغادراتهم
مناصبهم من اجل فرزها كما لا توجد ممارسات
سابقه تسمح بذلك مضيفا ان القانون يسمح
لهم بذلك قبل ترك مناصبهم ونفى البيان ان
يكون الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما قد احتفظ
بالسجلات رئاسيه بعد مغادرته منصبه